los rostros vuelven a sentarse hoy a la
mesa con su viejo enemigo de los años 80
los talibán acuden a la capital rusa con
la esperanza de encontrar respaldo
aunque saben que moscú todavía no está
dispuesta a reconocerlos oficialmente
como gobierno el encuentro se centra en
la situación política y militar de
afganistán y también en la formación de
un gobierno que moscú espera que sea
inclusivo rusia busca ahora un nuevo
liderazgo diplomático en afganistán y
por eso se sienta de la mano con china y
pakistán para echar una mano en la nueva
andadura afgana eeuu no se ha apuntado a
esta ronda pero ha dicho que se sumara
en el futuro el represante del
incremento se encargó de rebajar las
expectativas por anticipado diciendo que
no esperaba gran cosa de esta reunión
que no creía que hoy se produjese en
avances importantes moscú quiere esperar
a ver cuáles son los pasos de los
talibán sobre todo quiere saber si van a
respetar las fronteras de los países
limítrofes algunos de ellos son íntimos
aliados de rusia